have you done Molly
I can't believe that's a real question
you're asking her it's so crazy because
I we don't like what in high school it
was called ecstasy oh it is that true
yeah
this show is sponsored by better help
find more balance with Better Health
visit betterhealth.com trash Tuesday
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday Esther
don't you love peaches
um life is more exciting when there's
peaches involved go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply Spike Peach that's
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer naturally flavored with
other natural flavors simply spico
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday hey
sluggies happy Tuesday I am on the road
you can come see me in San Antonio on
June 23rd and 24th at the LOL Comedy
Club I also will be in Philadelphia in
August at the punchline and you can see
me in Austin Texas at the Vulcan gas
company October 6th through 7th I also
have dates in San Francisco San Jose and
a lot of really cool places so go to
annieleterman.com shows and you can see
me every Thursday
at 12 p.m PST on YouTube on anniewood
with me and Todd come check it out hi
slugs I am so happy and excited to be
back on the road sharing my crazy stand
up with all of you we are going to have
so much fun at these shows I will be in
New York City July 19th through 22nd I
will be in DC September 28th and Boston
at the Wilbur September 30th and more
get tickets at astronize.com I cannot
wait to have fun with you guys this
summer and this fall
thank you
[Music]
one time I overheard the older girls in
dance class talking about how if you
haven't
o r g a s m I can't read
that if you have an orgasm
uh during is that origami that's when
you fold this together until you squirt
if you have one if you go go during an
ecstasy High then you'll never really go
go the same again that's some dumb [__]
that's not true no is it harder to come
on Molly to even care to come because
everything feels like a come
I'm not I don't think a living orgasm
right you're like yeah
thank you I'm trying to figure out this
leg harness you guys it's it's this loud
turn off the shoulder I never thought
I'd say this to you but I think your
shoulder might be too small for this
I literally my I've never never occurred
to me also before we started rolling I
was like just squeeze in it and then I
realized it was a shoulder issue and I
was like [__] this is not right wait is
Molly something you've only done like in
your younger year I don't like this this
talk to the hand nonsense that talk to
the hand is so we can we bring that back
yes
like no one has seriously said that in
35 years
I mean this is like not I think my step
dad does
I'm [__] scream at this little hand
wait is it something that you do as an
adult or just as a teenager everyone
does it when's the last time you did
Molly they even have a Molly assisted
Psychotherapy now yes I swear to God in
the same vein that's where it started
that's where it came from listen to me
[__] no I'm gonna I'm gonna therapy 101
you yes tell her Annie tell her that's
where it started it started in couples
therapy that's where they found out
found ecstasy it was a pill they were
given couples so that they would like
rekindle their love for each other what
does anybody want to look that up so I
can show Esther how smart I am I believe
you don't worry wait so I'm like I'm
like I have a PhD in drugs that that I
do believe in college drugs that college
did not take me eight years to graduate
what I'm asking is Molly something like
adults okay you know how like it's
something you would love to do yes
adults do it you know I Like Cocaine
it's like cool party scene yeah adults
Molly is that Molly's more I think Molly
and Coke are equal and why is it called
Molly and ecstasy ecstasy was just what
was around when we were in high school
and it was like more coke involved in it
and it was like cut with more stuff and
then Molly is the pure Christmas how are
you alive
uh because I lived baby how are how have
you existed the song without living it's
been really hard you've weakened
Bernie's yourself through life it's it's
not easy it requires a lot of planning
and strategy but I am oh no I'm sorry
Andres I had to pull up like an abstract
isn't that the last one you looked
something up and it's like not just like
you guys like I want you guys he pulled
up ncbi like that is what we use as a
resource for nursing school also honest
is this not the worst experience when
you open something it's like the
abstract the introduction you're like
are you I'm going to college can I get a
Wikipedia I tried to stop you from
looking it up
don't you think like I am our um Google
needs to be better about having the ones
where it's just like the random question
you click on it and there's just like
one highlighted answer that's what chat
GPT is for now we just ask it with the
machine questions and the Machine tells
us how pretty we are you guys I want to
say that I think I'm fully Tangled and
I'm sure I put this all wrong you're
Tangled you're Tangled did you push it
in I the the shoe with a nail tell
everyone what happened okay so um I
bought these today and today today
because I was like oh oh you like had a
retail experience today I did and I
never go out to shop you guys know this
so what happened was I ordered this for
next day pickup on Monday and I went to
go pick it up on Tuesday it wasn't there
I went to go pick up yesterday it wasn't
there because apparently it's all
everything sold out from EDC oh yes and
so between Coachella between Stagecoach
between there was nothing left this was
all that was left this dress and this
harness so I was like give me those
[__] boots and when I put them on
there were two Nails sticking up so I
impaled myself while putting them in so
I I actually I'm not I'm not putting my
foot all the way to the is this like a
Filipino thing that you're good at this
yeah because it for Easter like we do
crucify real people
with your uncle right yes it's just a
family it's just genetic guys she's like
it's Stigmata
Pete will you introduce the theme today
since it was your idea I mean by the way
we need to unpack outs Pizza idea I mean
that's where I am trying well I heard
this thing called EDC so very uh
producer like I'm like hey uh let's do
EDC that's it dance music I think it's
Electric Daisy Carnival oh really oh
that sounds so much like the OG OG but
you know what I like about trash Tuesday
our theme is like we'll like pretend we
go to a thing and not go to it yeah
well that's by the way the only reason
people go to Coachella dress up yeah
which don't maybe they like listen to
them I feel like that wasn't a theme
this year though I feel like everyone
dressed down for Coachella yeah but it's
still about how you looked when you were
there it was about dressing down like
don't you feel like if you were
performing at a show like Coachella
where it's more about how the audience
is dressed you'd be like why what the
[__] [__] you guys I want all of my
audience members to come dressed like
they are on Molly Ecstasy see I want
mine they are going to a sleepover like
they're sleeping
you know what to make it make sense when
they fall asleep during your set
like they're Hugh Hefner you know at one
of his big parties in like fancy pajamas
well I know this must happen to you on
the road because people come to my shows
dressed like you they're like I wore my
Esther outfit and they're like by the
way I heard a fan told on you what that
you gave away it's so [__] up you
literally begged me for a sleepover by
Esther and then a fan told me that you
threw threw it out to the crowd and gave
it away but what was it was it it was a
it was an old it was like one of the
ones okay well they they did tell a
shitty one no before it was named it was
like one of those I was like I'm not
gonna okay I was cleaning out my closet
and I was being very realistic I was
like okay no no it wasn't a [__] I'd
never give away your [__] the one I
begged by the way you can it's fine no
no I gave away your um the one that like
remember there was one that was good and
I didn't get it and I was like why is
that one good and you're like Dave made
remember when you were the fit it was
like the P colored one
I'm like sorry [__] I can't keep this
in my [__] class of her when you got
naked in front of Dave well it was on
his work and I was like bending over
spreading my butt cheeks and he was
really upset like really can we go to
writer's strike
wait a second I want to ask you guys I
know you're really into sleepovers but I
was never allowed to go to any of them
when I was younger would you allow your
kids to go on a sleepover
today we that's actually such a good
question oh I was never where I said I
was gonna be I was like in another lady
I was like hitchhiking no young young
Annie like I'm talking about like six
seven years old I would have to know the
parents yeah I'd have to trust the
parents and then to set up mm-hmm if
there's anyone else in the house like
the the person's older brother like I
would be sorry
I don't want to say this because I feel
like when you say this you manifest it
but my kids will not be getting diddled
I'm so sorry it's just like not gonna
happen so whatever I have to do to make
sure that happens I think no sleep my my
policy is no sleepovers you're making me
realize like my parents never gave a
[__] where I slept and you didn't get
diddled which is a [__] miracle I was
never allowed sleepovers but then I got
diddled at home it's like so sad it's
just like took you so long to get hot
and you're still like baby hot which is
the weird thing
like literally they I in high school I
met girls and we had a sleepover the
same night we met I never went home my
parents never tried like nobody cared
where I slept
do you guys care because they were
asleep at not even a little bit
um they were asleep at nine [__] they
didn't know they didn't care wait your
parents you know what your parents tell
you though because you have this too
what I think you do maybe I'm wrong but
I think you they taught you like good
self-care
expand on that like to go to bed at nine
and not give a [__] that your kid is
like up it's like it's like above all
like above all like we will get our B
-sleep handle your life [__] adults
first like they totally prioritize
themselves and you love the rejection of
it that's why you want to live back in
the basement you're like I want my
parents to like not do everything like
they'll do stuff with you but like you
you like that they won't do all did your
parents prioritize themselves over you I
get the fives that they did
my mom's biggest mistake she made when
but she was also like a pushover like
she wanted us to really like her so she
would like let us do whatever we wanted
and then even just doing that like a
thought that your mom even had enough of
a personality to want to be liked and
like my mom is like a blank canvas of a
human but I think she wants to be like
too but she she like learned though
Stepford Wives my mom yes yeah but
that's like she just likes I mean she's
like she's kind of like your mom's
basically like more in the moment than
all of us like she's like cleaning it's
true yes she is she's like there's a
task at hand and she's like stop with
your nonsense even her voice when we
talked to her like ever it's like she's
like hey okay all right sure I'm in the
middle of something but it's fine what
have you ever seen your mom very
emotional or like really just [__] like
big big emotions oh man no no if me no
I've seen my mom drive me to the wrong
like she would drive me to like swim
class when I was supposed to be going to
school in the wrong place and she would
be so much like I'm an idiot like she
would literally be like what team
Phillips
Hoffman and uh Boogie Nights
I think it's okay we don't even like
swim practice
um but my mom her biggest mistake she
ever made was she sent us to this we
lived right by the park the TW Park
we're so lucky that is so long I don't
know I'm jealous I'm blessed I really
look back on my life even though I was
raped in less than every hole it's still
like worth the location you know what I
mean living near a park
and I was treated like a park all those
people came in and out whenever they
wanted
they climbed you people played
basketball inside me and my they they're
able to get nothing but net
um but so they sent us to like the local
camp that was at the TW camp
and um and we were I'm not even kidding
like we walked through my neighbor's
yard to get to the camp people would
walk through our yard to get to that's
how close we're to the park my mom's
because she was lazy and didn't want to
go pick us up or not lazy let me reframe
that I love my mom she was working on
whatever extracurricular thing she was
doing like she was always like writing a
book or doing she worked which is by the
way absolutely incredible no no now what
she's doing she's on like her third book
in the past like four years yeah but to
me the fact that you're honestly this is
like worth noting the fact that she was
Raising you [__] and like then low-key
in her private time writing like that's
amazing yeah but there's no private time
it's the thing is your name man she also
was spending a lot of time in the
bathtub reading romance novels and I was
like can someone teach me to read I
can't read can someone show me I guess
it wasn't the right book it was easier
for her to write papers robbing but it
was out of like love yeah it was like
codependency stuff yeah but so she she
didn't want to have to like leave her
right in to go pick us up from Camp so
she signed off a thing that we could
leave camp like by ourselves but she
didn't realize there was this wait how
old were you we were like
seven to ten maybe okay the camp was
next to us yeah also there was three of
you right so it's like I do see there's
you could be looser as a parent when
there's three there may have been one
that wasn't really like included with
the others which is who
she may have to dress wild to get
attention
dress like a kooky nine-year-old woman
to get attention but
um so we found the loophole in that and
realized we could just come home
any time of day it didn't say like they
can leave by themselves at this time it
just said they can leave so we would go
to Camp you're like this is boring and
just come home my mom would be like why
are you home like you signed the thing
[__] she wouldn't send you back I mean
what are we gonna go we're gonna listen
to her we're back already let's wait
we're here we're watching TV I'm already
eating popsicles getting insight into
what kind of paranoid because it'd be
like I paid for you to be at that camp
you're gonna be there you would send
your kid your camp with your heritage
[Laughter]
Dave was a camp counselor and why did it
make me so turned on Legit I was like
because you weren't molested so
you were not Melissa so you're like it's
desperate to like play like molested and
you do read young so you can still like
thank you there's no time yeah do you
would you not be into like a camp
counselor role play because the reason
that I wouldn't be is because I got
um molested everybody
crystals I'm squeezing my Yoni egg I'm
squeezing my Yoni like the truth is
um when the last time I was in a
psychiatric hospital okay
um Everybody Take a Shot
so this is the third time I was in the
psych hospital this is in Torrance my
brother was still alive
I'm still banging we were still banging
um that brother or possapp brother it's
not brother brother she's had sex with a
brother that might be biological yeah
but will we ever know I think we don't
know will we ever get that answer but it
still counts yeah the sex counted okay
but you know you know we'll keep it as a
maybe do you wait do you have dick uh
no because he was the brother he was the
brother yeah he was the brother best
brother good step brother perfect penis
I was like oh my God for being my
stepbrother you have a baby
second brother his he was the one who
got circumcised a little too much and so
his dick wouldn't fully expand and it
would hurt him but he had I remember
having like a really big Untamed Bush
and but it really sex was great with him
um anyways back to my um when I tried to
unalive myself when I was 17 and I went
to a psych Hospital in Torrance
um right after
um I had a counselor there who on my
last day helped me pack
and he slipped me his number yes oh I
remember that his name
um he was all I'll say is he wear a lot
of Aeropostale
um and I remember that he was a single
dad it could be on this episode and I
went on a couple dates with him because
in my head I didn't think there was
anything wrong with it but I'm like oh
this was somebody that sat in on all of
my sessions and
um knows that I'm here because I wanted
to kill myself and those all of my
psychiatric problems uh 16. did we ever
talk about we there were some of them no
no it's the same subject it's the same
subject please let it not we have the
same subject did we ever talk about you
know we all know someone that had passed
away had taken our own life and they
found out that she was having like an
affair with her therapist remember this
oh yes yes yes wait remind me yeah so
this art of this this this really like
amazing kind of shiny star it took her
own life this was a little while ago and
then this article came out that she had
her psychiatric or psychiatrist had been
having an affair with her I did not know
about this yes and when I read it I
looked him up I went to him he gave me
Adderall he gave me Adderall on day one
pretty weird he gave on day one and he
did give me word Vibes but I only went
to get Adderall anyways how did that
come out there was an article about it
yeah there was how does everyone know
this but me
that's really I don't know maybe the
Twilight Zone was doing like a marathon
though oh it was New Year's Day okay
fair enough
of course you'd know
maybe Wicked came to this to the yeah
but that is [__] up that's a little
bit different that will be coming in
2024. another thing that happened to me
that was [__] up brace yourself was
quite kind of the opposite bring this
back
um the first person the first therapist
I ever had was this amazing amazing guy
he was just a school counselor and he
was incredible and he helped me really
figure out like what I was feeling name
my feelings
but then I had a swim coach who I know I
know thank you for doing that my eyes
were doing the nystagmus thing but then
I had another adult in my life who was
my swim coach at that time basically
call my dad and say hey I think
something is something fishy is going on
with her therapist oh no and I Dr actual
platonic and it actually [__] blocked my
joy because he was helping me out so
much he was so decent so appropriate
never ever got any weird vibes from him
and I don't know if that's his my my
that dude's own projection or if he was
seeing something wait the guy who you
did hook up with did that
I didn't hook up with anybody at this
time I like that Oliver's fighting over
wait sorry I was wait
you're masturbational wait wait what's
this
okay but maybe he was seeing an
inappropriate maybe he was never there
he never met him he just knew that I was
in therapy in school and I never said
anything so I was very surprised that
when he was like I think he something is
going on I'm like what in the [__] are
you talking about this person was so
decent and so helpful
and uh I I I and also I had beef with
that coach like he there was something
something going on there when when I the
first time that I was hospitalized and
put it in a psych hospital for my first
attempt he announced it to the whole
swim team really yeah he sat everybody
down my best friend was on the swim team
I was I was at bhc and now Alhambra look
that blood that you saw streaming next
to Lila was not her period She had slit
her wrists imagine how [__] up that is
15. and you guys just been on vacation
or something they'd have to say yeah he
sat everyone down he's like guys I just
want to let you know that kalila is in
the hospital because she tried to commit
suicide I call you cuckoo they didn't um
Kiki what was that close what on Earth
could he have thought the point of that
I don't know he's trying to [__] listen
with kalila if there's a question yeah
but I I had a boyfriend that said to me
that one said that to me when she goes
if you've ever had like an issue with a
guy like just really really considered
they're mad you didn't [__] them and I
was like that's a lot of advice
that works
I really love therapy because therapy
can give you the tools that you need to
find more balance in your life so you
can keep supporting others without
leaving yourself behind and we are so
happy that this show is sponsored by
Better Health Therapy is uh so annoying
to get into it's such a big step it's
like such a big like like great thing
you can do for yourself that when I
first started therapy it was you had to
find the place that took your insurance
you had to find where it was located you
had to print out a MapQuest oh you had
to drive you had to find parking you had
to have like an awkward time in the
waiting room and then you go in and the
therapist you don't even like they don't
even you don't even Vibe and then you
have to start all over again and it's so
hard with better help this is like the
best way to just kind of start dipping
your toe into therapy it's all online
you can switch your therapist whenever
you want and therapy is helpful for
learning positive coping skills and how
to set boundaries it empowers you to be
the best best version of yourself it
isn't just for those who've experienced
major trauma like it can really level up
your life no matter what your situation
is like even if you don't think you've
experienced trauma like it's America
something yeah and I really like what
you um I like that idea that you don't
have to wait for a crisis in your life
to happen to
um pursue therapy I think therapy is for
everybody it's a good place to just lay
your heavy thoughts down or you know
have somebody an unbiased professional
be there to kind of like work out you
know aspects of your life even if it's
not even if you're not in a crisis it's
just like I think about it as like
keeping your grass green hmm I love that
and if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief question
here to get matched with a licensed
therapist and switch therapist at any
time for no additional charge find more
balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help help.com trash Tuesday I
believe that life is more exciting when
Peaches are involved and that's why
we're brought to you by simply spiked
Peach from the makers of Simply spiked
lemonade simply spiked Peach is now
available 21 and up only and it contains
alcohol okay you guys summer is coming
up and I'm really excited that simply
Spike has a new flavor and it's Peach I
know it's a cute girly flavor for once
and it's so refreshing it's kind of the
perfect drink like if you're showing up
to a summer party like you want to bring
something that's kind of a new product
that not everyone has tried I think
simply spiked Peach is so ideal so girly
to bring and all flavors of Simply
spiked are crafted with five percent ABV
and five percent real fruit juice
squeezed then concentrated this spring
simply spiked has introduced a new
flavor that fans have been asking for
since day one simply spiked Peach pick
up a variety pack today to try all four
new fresh flavors they have other than
Peach they have strawberry peach kiwi
Peach and mango peach
simply spiked Peach is the newest
addition to the simply spiked family
joining simply spiked lemonade which
broke the internet when it dropped last
summer with its four bold and refreshing
flavors signature lemonade strawberry
lemonade blueberry lemonade and
watermelon lemonade go to
drinksimplyspike.com trash Tuesday to
find out how to get your hands on new
simply Spike Peach that's
drinksimplyspiked.com trash Tuesday
flavored beer natural flavored with
other natural flavors simply spiked Co
Milwaukee Wisconsin celebrate
responsibly simply spiked as a trademark
of the Simply Orange Juice company
we on my drive here I saw a billboard of
um Chaz Dean and I wanted to ask you
guys like is he a real person or is he
AI real person Chas Dean has been real
for centuries he said he's been a hair
person yes he's the inventor you know
how much this Chaz Dean ruined my life
he invented a form of shampoo that is
basically just conditioner so I thought
that that oh like this is a life hack
you just when yeah yes w-e-n let me tell
you that does not work it was really bad
I just was like greasy thick lotiony
hair
but I see all these Billboards he almost
doesn't look like a real person so I was
like wait a second like I mean have you
seen Nicole Goodman at the AMC thing I'm
going to see so many horror movies and
we Todd and I always scream when Nicole
Kidman goes downstairs like oh the movie
didn't start yet
I watched Eyes Wide Shut it's oh we just
watched it too you did yes so good it's
so eerie and I had no idea it was going
to be so weird it was so amazing when I
do Pilates with that [__] Nicole
Kidman body I have to say no no no I
have to say that I was like I'm so much
more into my body than like that respect
she's beautiful but let's say Tom Cruise
like this super I'm actually I'm like
this is where I'm grateful for the
Kardashians is like the super tall super
thin like perfect ideal woman I'm like
it's not doesn't do it for me they did
start making people tall sideways though
[Music]
you'd have to really maybe your diaper
butt can count as a yeah no but I just
think like I really do I don't know
maybe this is me becoming like more
lesbian but like I love a real woman's
body wait I do too if I think about
girls I'm attracted to yeah I I always
think of a little bit more meat you know
what I will say about softness Nicole
Kidman's body and eyes wide chat that I
liked as a small Titty Committee I loved
fair enough the boo the little boobies I
love but she doesn't have those small
boobs anymore
but it was like a weird it was a weird
thing to see um big little lies you
didn't see I don't remember yeah it's
just it's weird to see the progression
for sure yeah I'm just like oh my God I
forgot my stickers you guys that was the
essential part of my outfit I thought I
glitter too for some reason I just
thought there'd be glitter in my car I
told Kyle I was like I think I have
glitter in my cars no this is there
wasn't there's a lot of other stuff in
there speaking of ice Wide Shut I got
these oh does that go over for each
um boob it says I'm horny I have a
banana tattoo
oh my God she's now she thinks those
fake tattoos are tattoos and the oh yeah
this is this is actually a story
I know you don't want to talk about your
sexuality even though we brought it up
every single episode but um that's the
fun part if you don't want it and again
I don't even know that you don't have to
answer this question but have you had
full-blown sex with just the woman not
in the context of a threesome just with
a woman no not full-blown doesn't she
look disappointed in herself yeah it's
not okay
I feel bad for you thank you I love
that's my favorite place to be it's when
people feel bad for me
that's my comfort zone because well I
just feel like you deserve that
experience right now a lot of people at
home are making you feel weird
head full mine is always in the context
of a threesome but I had no I had with
just a girl but I told her she got like
two knuckles in and I was like do you
want to smoke a Newport
what are we doing here I just she was
she had like short her shed masculine
trades and she
was very interested in me
exploring whether or not I was a lesbian
but I just had never wasn't she pushy
though she was a little pushy she was a
little seed planty but I but I was
susceptible to be seated so I was
fertile there was fertile ground fertile
um but and I'm glad that I tried it and
stuff but in the end I just it wasn't
[Music]
um
like a hard deck when you had a
threesome with a fellow peer of ours oh
my God who will remaining with her the
other day when she sent me a picture of
one of those shoes like she just sends
me pictures of like the the place we
went to when you had a threesome did you
guys have any interaction yes you did
yeah yeah we made out played with each
other's boobs
yeah but that's fun that's CR I'm liking
it was really you know what I will be
honest I did feel very like sexual like
I felt like really like I like I felt
very um
in my element having two people there
and like one's a girl and once again it
just felt good because I think I'm like
pretty masculine in my life so it was
like to be feminine be able to be
feminine and masculine with two
different people I love that whoa I I
feel like yeah one of my best friends
I've definitely had a threesome with and
we're still good friends I just saw her
last week is there any does she fly to
[__] first when you see her and you
know what she's really soft and needy
she's really really like
thick beautiful like meaty body but no
we had this thing when I was in in Ibiza
when I was in a Visa we we had when we
were in Ibiza uh 2 000. I thought we
were gonna be like two weeks ago we
trash Tuesday there those episodes are
coming wait Andre's just for our own
enjoyment can you say the word Ibiza
Ibiza okay Ibiza
today we learn
um also Andres are you like a permanent
part of our show now I'm uh the new
fixture yes and what's okay wow well
should we like welcome you what if
people don't know you wait fancy have
you been to a rave I have yeah where
that's where you got your name right
right
he's quite a dancer are you a good
dancer I am he is a good dancer yeah
that comes with your like Heritage it's
just in the blood yeah yeah it's like
roll your r's and you can also like
right you're like a real man like you're
a husband and a father and like you work
what is that like you have a Castilian
accent when you speak so you
it's cute
[Laughter]
well it's like we have to like husband
daddies here right they they need to
keep us in line they're just like my
ladies are breastfeeding what are my
other ladies
it's so funny P came up with this idea
and then I was like oh my God is pee
like a secret raver and then he's like
no I just heard about it I
thought we were like unfolding something
um I
I had this thought besides Chaz Dean
being an AI on the way over like when do
you think sex became a a private thing
to do like you know in the animal world
where you know we're supposed to come
from apes and ever you know Apes just
[__] anywhere in front of us there's no
regard for privacy when when in that
lineage do you think someone said I I
think they should be behind closed doors
and should it really be behind closed
doors or just we have we just been
programmed to believe that that's the
right thing to do yeah it's got to be
religion it's God Catholic it's
definitely a religion and then you know
in the 60s it was like the undoing of
that and then it was like everyone's
getting herpes and everything so then
they're like all right maybe we can
close this down a little bit wait Andres
do you know that is it really
well because if you think about like
when the Romans and the Greeks were you
know they would have sexuality was way
more
um Lively right even homosexuality just
came in with the church and that was can
I ask you a question yeah Andres are you
23 or 47
neither but are you 35
I only guess 41. no that state is that
Dave's 43. oh Dave is so much older than
that so you guys how old are you Pete
wait wait I want to guess I want to
guess
you're 40. three
40 30 39 no he's younger than he looks
Puerto Rican knocked up right away
that is she Spanish oh she is I thought
she was I can't wait for all the
comments to like imagine if they get if
this was the other way around it's also
like those people why are you watching
this is for girls and cool guys okay not
guys that are like I can't wait to poke
holes in women's stories
like what it's like this is not for you
comment on the Reddit we know you guys
are on Reddit go to Reddit
my favorite is like when they try to
poke holes in your molestation stories
no they don't what well yeah oh my God
my dad doesn't believe you guys that's
right that's right
um
um but no I I was just thinking to
myself it's like did the Catholics just
inject shame into everything into the
fun stuff they were like enough fun what
bring shame wait can I say more to the
yes the trolls I actually like that
you're here because it's funny to me the
idea that they're just watching getting
so mad every time we like talk about
something that's like feminine oh these
girls are talking about girl things this
is so annoying these girls are being
girls they're talking about
oh
it's like you guys you meant you go we
know your secret your biologically
programmed to want to [__] us at all
times sorry
he's like shut up they're like pick
which one they like them by the way you
competitively throw us against each
other I [__] this one over this one
but like I wouldn't throw this one out
of bed it's like
fighting for their two girls that will
never touch you we only shoot me that
I'll [__] three I thought he said two
girls those are the lesbians
listen I've seen some girls that look
like boys at these shows and you have a
better chance for that story I will say
that okay I didn't even add you in
I'm not really here do you I don't count
holy
no but yeah oh you know what I actually
do like is the the people who comment
that they watch this like before jerking
off they're like this is like a soft way
in to getting horny like that I'm like
okay that's like somebody like you know
more than I give you the time stamp of
when they came like that's pretty early
it okay girls it's creative I like it
because you know what sometimes just
straight up porn is boring and you need
to really like set the tone and you need
to kind of get mad at some girls for
talking about sex when you're jerking
off you're like oh my God you really
ruined my boner you're talking about sex
yeah they want us to go slower
and be more innocent it's just so funny
Todd's up when he's like what are these
men doing on here like why would they go
to a girl's podcast and expect them to
be like talking about boys like talking
like boys yeah maybe my fans it makes
sense sweet
um
I know also Kira told me this like years
ago but speaking of men's coming
men's arousal wait I know I'm still mad
that it's Catholics that ruin sex for
all of us I'm Jewish that's not fair to
me you don't think the Jews um I should
care about typically have sex to like
reclaim this they that's everybody would
like that there's no one's saying no
except maybe your parents or like Esther
come on like the only problem is that
like I wouldn't want some dude just
swing his dick around and following me
anywhere right but if it's just two
people like consensually being like you
know why can't we [__] right here I do
not want to publicly have sex that's a
choice but I'm just saying like a couple
people in the room but I don't want like
a crowd to form around and be like go go
go correct me if I'm wrong though would
you you
would take a [__]
out right that's a Vibe I get not like
spread but like I'll be on the toilet
squeezing
I don't want the camera to be like in
the toilet all right you're the opening
of your stand-up Special
by the way trying to squeeze one out
before you get on stage that's relatable
it is relatable listen especially that
comedy star bathroom sometimes I hear
them saying my name and like I have not
even pulled the toilet paper
I'm like be right there we okay kalila
what about men coming so um do you have
a headache are you pushing your stickers
I don't know what I'm doing I don't it's
weird to have a hairstyle it's like a
foreign
not to make you guys uncomfortable but I
do want to ask the boys when a girl when
you see a girl putting her hair back is
that like automatically make you
beautiful jobs yeah no and not they're
at work
what do you mean like in a ponytail
literally just a girl going like this is
like makes every man think of a [__]
is what I what
I can't even do this anymore oh that's
sexually assaulting men I mean your
mouth is very like blow Joby yeah I know
I have blow job mouth I know it's a
curse it's kind of like a little bit
like hot scrapey teeth no so I have like
a little draggy could drag yeah if you
like slight drag I will slide drag I
give like a like a prickly mustache
[__]
you know I'm so lazy that when I give a
[__] it's extra throat saliva and I
do a lot of like half hand so I just
don't like it's just it's just sloppy so
it's good it's good because I I that's a
life hack for me it's like if you're
lazy this is done hey how do we get this
done we gotta throw it get what through
what you just finished how do we finish
the [__] we got stuff to do yeah I
think mine have been called like like
Angels so it's like come on oh my god
get some clips going yeah I'm sorry if
that is the clip done
yeah if you require like a beach to
complete like no thank you don't date me
like yeah the [__] should be the
beginning of yeah yeah and you can come
in my mouth but we're not gonna do it
from beginning to end like that is not
uh why did you take it like she said
that to your Defender
I unless you're like a three minute guy
then I'm all about it
yes then it's like thank you Jesus for
giving me this sweet sweet like this the
same topic as the men coming topic you
were trying to get to or no this is
different so the the the the thing I
wanted to ask will talk about was
basically this that they did a study and
I huberman talked about it recently but
I actually heard about this study long
ago when I uh I was podcasting with
asakira and she basically says that
um well the study basically says that
um crying and tears has a hormonal
effect on men's arousal so in this
experiment where uh men um there was a
control group and then there was uh
women's like tears that they would have
to smell
um there was an effect on their hormone
for so they decreased arrival when they
say a woman cry basically decrease I've
not had that experience and second of
all it's a meaner man
yeah so I was like oh my God my God
because I've kind of had the opposite
yes no I have guys my ex-boyfriend was
like you look so hot when you cry and
I'm like same with Bobby he would see me
like we're gonna get into a fight why
you do this to me is that why you're
yelling at me but then I had recently
started dating another guy and when I
would be vulnerable and cry he would
call it the intimacy boners he was like
oh I feel honored that you're telling me
this stuff and you're emotional I didn't
make you less horny though no it didn't
is this science you're healing I am
healing I'm like oh my God because I saw
this study and that's why I was so
surprised by it like it says that tears
are when men smell women's tears it
decreases arousal but you both are
spreading lies that that is not the case
you guys think that men get horny from
tears I'm just like you're like fight
because you're on like an antidepressant
can't cry or something which one why are
you taking this so personally I'm just
so I think I'm not I think the science
is really I haven't cried in months and
nobody's had a boner you guys it's
either you guys or the science when was
the last time you cried in front of a
guy in front of your partner I cried at
intermission of wicked a few no that
doesn't count
did you think Dave's boner did he [__]
you that night wait were you crying were
you crying because you were moved
because there were still half of the
show left or because you weren't in it
or because
by the way David and iron saying you
paid for the Twitter mark we don't care
no it went away
yesterday
I want to tell you I was in so much
cycle and yesterday by the way the cycle
ended
I wouldn't know it had
Esther it happened you know I did not
pay for Twitter blue I had a check mark
and it's gone now mysteriously and I
cross your legs
inside we know the truth crosses don't
count or whatever wait no I I'm happy to
be one of the people now I have no blue
check mark I'm just like you I'm just
like all of you my people the day it
mattered is over there was one day where
it was the coolest thing in the world to
not have a check mark and you missed
that so it was so unfair you are the
only one no I was crying she texted me
last night and she was like the Twitter
mark thing is real I'm like yes well I
looked at mine I wasn't even really
aware because I was just what I was
talking about in the last episode was
Instagram verification yeah I wasn't
even aware of what you guys were talking
about so I look back I was like oh I
don't have my blue check mark anymore
neither does Bobby Knight is anyone I
know mine mine is gone now
and I know the timer recurring payments
wait she used rocket money
[Laughter]
that this is happening
I would be so honest about paying I
would be proud to invest in my career
that way I would be so proud of that
payment guys please use rocket money
just like your Queen Esther wait but you
guys um all the cool boys that are
listening to this I I want to know we
want to know like if if you see a girl
cry like what do you like can you take
note of that feeling is it like up is it
going down or is it a neutral like no
net effect like I really do want to know
and this is what I have a theory okay if
this is somehow about my check mark
You're Fired yourself no you have the
kind of you go of someone that would pay
for their check mark Annie you did dress
like a blue check mark
that's unfair
getting like a check mark
if I had been more well I would have
been going so hard on you on Twitter I
was just I was not not well but
um what's your theory okay so my
boyfriend be like he would literally
time out fights like you look really fun
I mean this is when I'm like it's not
bubble crying you know what I realized
you know what I think it was
it's filler natural failure face it's
like oh your lips get puffy the salt yes
I forgot you do look hotter after you
cry oh majorly especially if you have a
big night like night before cry the
morning after when you wake up you have
natural Fox Eye wait what is it you have
Fox Eye right now is it the makeup it's
the makeup I don't know about the
threads [__] I will never get the
threads those things they stay in but
then they don't work for that long well
no you also like the the
um the risk of having them exposed and
that's so that's almost like having a
check mark when no one else does to have
your friends exposed but I do want to
try micro needling I do want to try it
with you guys like I'm kind of afraid
can you explain what threads are for
people who don't I I don't I just know
that they put threads under your skin to
lift certain parts of your face and that
is terrifying for you know what I had it
okay no I was gonna say I had a hair
person recently ask if they could tape
your face
that you can do without permission ask
if they could tape do face tape yes and
I was like okay for a second and they
did it and I I was like was that for one
of your Paparazzi picture like oh my God
Esther's coming from the surgeon
no but I will never do like I did it for
two seconds I was like I don't want a
single photo with it because I don't I
don't want filters I don't want like do
you remember the one Clayton posted a
video that was like it really was the
best picture I've ever seen Pro yeah he
probably like it was Doctor no gorgeous
that I and I remember you were like oh I
think he had face tuned or whatever and
then I was like I pay some rocket money
I pay so much money to face tune because
I want to like replicate what he there's
it's impossible it's an art form
I don't ever want to be face taped
because you guys when you do this when
you take the face tape off you're going
to look worse you're going to hate
yourself more I'm so against that I look
I think you can look good for a day and
still love yourself after no I don't
think so you need your breath work [__]
you know what I'm gonna do with my
parents my parents want me to do like a
makeover with them where I get the tape
for you for them oh oh my God your
parents are so different from mine's
like get the tape
now my parents want me to do like suck
their double chins and then stuff into a
photo shoot with them that'd be kind of
cute oh next time on vacation I'm
getting it for them
yeah I feel funny to see them all sucked
up yeah the funniest thing in the entire
world my dad
I'm weird
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place like I know I'm a sucker for
anything that says try this for 30 days
and of course I'm that person that
forgets to cancel the subscription I've
had the I've had to one time I paid for
like an anime thing for three years
without knowing
um I've downloaded the weirdest apps
like I don't even want to mention on
here one of them is an insect finder
Kyla you're not alone because over 80
percent of people have subscriptions
that they forgot about okay and let me
tell you when I was broker it would be
like I'm overdrawn for some reason that
you look and they're like I'm overdrawn
because of an app that I forgot it's so
embarrassing rocket money will quickly
and easily find your subscriptions for
you and for any that you don't want to
pay for anymore just hit cancel and raw
company will cancel it for you it's that
easy and over 3 million people have used
rocket money saving the average person
720 a year that is so much much money
rocket money also helps you manage all
your finances in one place and
automatically categorizes your expenses
so you can easily track your budget in
real time and also get alerted if
anything looks off you guys stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday
I have a question for you both I really
want you to think about this long and
hard
oh she said long and hard I guess what
guess what it's gonna be about oh well
everyone should be so mad it's all she
talks about is sex is it okay that your
partner has nudes and videos of Exes in
his hidden folder oh I'm so glad you
brought this up
do you know what's in Dave's hidden
folder
there there is no hidden folder are you
sure
is well hidden I would never ever date
someone who has hot exes
that's never gonna happen that's never
happening he she needs to be the yeah
there's not a chance if you have a hot X
I will never even look at you so you'll
do Intel before you even get serious
with a guy like you need to see what his
the lay of the land and his exit no okay
you go what do you think I was on Todd's
phone going through his pictures and I
saw a picture of my ass and I was like
oh I look pretty good oh that's not my
ass and I was like Titan he's like I
literally cannot delete this he's like
this x would kill me we talked about it
on anniewood he's like she would be so
upset if she knew I had this she's like
I swear I don't look at them I totally
believe him he's like I can't get off I
go give it to me I'm looking there's
literally no way to delete it it's
really weird I I looked at it there's no
way to delete it he's like show me how
to delete it it's on my phone it's like
I think it's because it got transferred
from another phone or something I have
no clue so it's like but he literally
can't here let me FaceTime it's a it's a
it's an ex's ass it's like his photo
album with her
but he's like I don't want to she would
be so upset if I had this why
because they broke up she doesn't want
him to have pictures of her and do you
does it make I know her I like her I
think she's so you don't care at all it
does not I don't I 100 try sod
and and when he said it I was like what
the hell is this and I was like you know
it's like and I told you his DMs I look
at his damns all the time constantly you
do yes we're all on each other's phones
like we're talking about boyfriends
having pictures of their exes
on their phone
oh my God everybody look at Todd tell us
what why can't you delete it because
they don't believe me because I saw it
and I knew you couldn't delete it
I tried to delete it I did try to delete
it
he sounds like he's lying but I swear
[__] how upset would this girl be she
would be so livid
she's a sweet girl I know her she's
sweet
I've been trying to give you he doesn't
want a new phone because I'm gonna make
him we found out Dave takes her
Paparazzi pictures
he doesn't want to have to take
Paparazzi pictures of me because his
phone's full will they really take some
of me I love you yeah oh yeah okay okay
back to my point about
um Partners having whatever
um
spank bank and
um videos and pictures of Exes in their
hidden folder I'll say this I had a
problem with it until I checked my own
hidden folder and I was like oh like I'm
a hypocrite because I cannot get rid of
any of this stuff so I judge myself on
my intention as a person where I'm like
well no like I'm keeping this for
Nostalgia and who actually like Jerk it
to that
sometimes that's never like while I was
in a relationship but in between
relationships I would look at them and
I'd be like [__] that was hot wait okay
is this a normal thing like thinking
about past sexual experiences I feel
like guys do this but I've never done
this have you done this Annie like
thinking about an ex and getting off to
that no I don't like any of my exes
also I'm more of a sender of pictures
than I get her pictures I'm not I don't
need any pictures well okay so my stuff
is more sex with the people that's what
it I don't keep dick pics like at all
like at all I don't feel like there's
any need for them I never ask for them
um but I do like watching myself like
you know do stuff oh I don't like that
I like it I like I have videos of dudes
eating my [__]
and do they know you're taking them are
you like yeah always like so this is
what I never have amnesia of the top of
there because you're wearing Velcro
it was like a little like they have to
sign a thing and it's basically like
agrees to the fact that I have a GoPro
mounted at all times I feel like
people's bodies in porn are so perfect
in every way that like if I took video
of myself having sex and then saw it I
would instantly be like the saddest I've
ever been in my life because I would
just look so like short and ugly
um that's how you view yourself but I'm
guessing if suppose you and Dave broke
up and she stumbled onto whatever sex
videos or photos she'd she'd oh want to
be sweating sweating so yeah what's the
verdict is it okay
no
okay got it it's not it's not right get
these [__] pictures off your phone
Todd can't I believe that
I believe him and it's like you know if
it's something he fights for so hard
that's weird why is he fighting so hard
okay good point like why would he like
why would that be such a big argument
it'd be like oh does this make you
uncomfortable okay I'll just delete them
I guess I respect you how you feel that
is the question so if if my partner did
ask me to delete it if it made him
uncomfortable it'll be like of course
and then put it in a more hidden hidden
video but the other thing that I have
learned which I learned this from a
Beverly Hills mom that I was a
babysitter for she I she's like keep
them on a Long Leash which that
essentially means like whenever you tell
a guy like oh you can't have this you
can't do that I feel like that just
makes them want it more and you're just
like you're screwing yourself over yeah
but then you're kind of not like that
the burden is on you to do the work why
can't they themselves have the like why
do you have to kind of like hand hold a
guy into not doing something like why
can't it just come from them to be like
you know what I'm not gonna do this
because maybe they don't know that it's
something that bothers you or maybe
they're just like not aligned that way
but it's like if you if you're being
extra jealous right but your boyfriend
loves you
then they should be supportive of you
working through your jealousy and
getting over your jealousy but just like
if your girlfriend doesn't care delete
them I really keep them yeah and if your
girlfriend cares to delete them it just
doesn't seem like I think it's okay only
if she's not hotter than me
yeah keep looking at those elgos that's
my bottom line like if you're like only
if you do a split shot of me
yeah only if you watch me right after
then I'm good
um but you brought this up recently that
like it actually does affect men's
Brains if they look at photos of
beautiful women like on Instagram or in
porn or whatever and I've always been so
confident and chill about that like I
don't care what guys are looking at but
like you're saying it actually will make
us look uglier to them it can it's not
it's not a hundred percent it will it
can for some men yeah to look at
idealized photos of women and I think
like
Dave doesn't seem like that type of guy
neither does Todd like they these people
hey look at that phone though
[Laughter]
um but I want to know something I want
to I want your opinion on this I
recently went home to the Philippines
and something was revealed to me that
was very very shocking from my family
all this you know everyone's just like
oh kovitz started in China
um these [__] Bobby you know saying a
bunch of like racist things about like
Chinese people and covet and whatnot
right
um I was in a van with like 16 of my
family members and everyone was like
what's your favorite fruit because like
there's a lot of fruits in the
Philippines that you like you've never
even heard of and they're so freaking
good and so we're like oh Santos and
we're naming all of them and all like
all of them and then one of my cousins
like oh like clock knit and we looked at
her and we're like wait that's not a
fruit that's a fruit bat
and she goes oh and I was like yeah
that's a [__] flying rodent that's
not a type of fruit and she was like
yeah we shoot and eat them all the time
so I think that my family started
covering you guys I think patient zero
is somewhere in my family there's no
such thing as bad publicity guys okay
Delilah says it here she started coven
come get her guys it's it started
somewhere yeah in the aves lineage like
that is and um I couldn't believe it I'm
like okay I really want you to start
like a niche Filipino smoothie shop with
all those flavors is that possible I
think people are already catching on to
Filipino flavors which is um like Ube
ubes everywhere now yeah but I grew up
with Uber ice cream right so um what
else is coming over here now
um I think sarasop is coming over but we
still have like maybe 50 more soursop
might need a rebranding of the name
soursop it's so good wait it sounds good
oh banana break
wow
[Music]
I feel like bananas are the perfect
I was like okay or whatever and
um it was like so muddy and I had mud I
had nothing to clean myself and I didn't
speak really good Spanish or anything so
I was basically just trapped like in mud
for my whole body did you someone gave
me a mango and I thought it was a good
idea but it wasn't a cut mango so I was
just biting into it so I had the strings
from the mango stuck in my teeth but I
was too dirty to get them out so I was
in just an absolute hell like my teeth
were being pushed apart I I will say
that mango strings I think like I can
once I eat a mango I have to have floss
nearby because it's more of like a
sensory aversion I have those mango
strings get stuck in there and will not
move
so that's a good point you're making at
you don't know lost your teeth with the
mango strings no they're so like hard
and fibrous where's my fingers either
though so there was like no
you know relief
I'm like getting so annoyed at mangoes
right now because when I think about
when they're good they're so good but
they're always like hard and
disappointing where are you getting your
mangoes
can we have a mango break one week I'll
choose the mangoes yeah
also I'll bring you Filipino mangoes
because what's the difference uh they're
just Heavenly over there we also should
do Hawaiian papaya break specifically
Hawaii oh I know I do not [__] with any
other yeah the big um the big uh
Southwestern papayas
no thank you
no thank you I don't know the difference
I don't know by region the the bigger
ones they smell a little bit more like
vomit
strong more vomit leaning when I threw
up when I threw up all over the bus when
we're going to the Mayan ruins when I
was on spring break
and uh High School Cinco de Mayo when I
was 14 and where I had all been just
drinking and getting so [__] up and my
school trip went to the ruins I threw up
all over everyone and the way the
teacher Justified it was like oh
sometimes people eat papaya and it makes
them throw up I said that was what it
does wasn't the Pina Coladas
I was thinking Annie about how you said
you want to give Todd like a script for
what to say to you and it made me think
of how like
Disney movies
made us think that men will just like
act magically the way we need them to
act and how we like we're just expecting
them to know what we want and actually
like I feel like the low-key secret to a
good relationship is telling the person
oh I like when you bring me this or when
you do that and it just was making me
think like what are other things we
could tell guys
like because whenever I've communicated
act when instead of like me sitting
there being like I wish Dave would do
this like if I just tell him he always
says to me like I can't read your mind
like you need to tell me and I feel like
that messaging again like we want to
just like blame guys because they don't
do what we expect them to but it's so
much better if you just like you said
give him a script but how many times do
you have to tell them is the question
because I I'm fine
you write the script you laminate you
type it okay so there's no misspelling
they don't have to read it this is how I
feel loved you don't have to worry about
your
um handwriting you laminate it you make
a couple copies three whole points put
it in a binder and it's laminated so you
can put it in the shower too have in the
shower that's so smart because showering
is probably where they're most focused
I yeah I think that it's important to
um communicate your needs but I think um
sometimes
um there are Partnerships where the
person is just not [__] listening so
they expect you to just always tell them
what to do and I can't have that I can't
do the hand holding anymore I cannot
[__] hold your hand like just
come as a whole thing like I don't want
to have I'm not I'm done with
fixer-uppers
wait that's like no I mean I understand
I'm a 38 there's there's no reason why I
should
um try to seek anyone who's still trying
to get there you're not 39 or 30 or 39.
I'm 38. oh you are yeah I'll be 39 soon
are we gonna cross over no you're gonna
turn 40 before I turn 39 [__]
we also I saw Gwyneth Paltrow was on
caller Daddy and she said that when she
turned 40 like you basically get a
software upgrade like you just wake up
and you're like your system is better
and you know how to prioritize yourself
more and I'm just curious have you guys
ever turned an age or like had like a
life event that made you feel like you
had a software upgrade I just have all
the people that I cannot relate to
like you look at certain people I'm like
oh I could probably relate to her like
Gwyneth Paltrow was like at the bottom
you're not like a bone broth [__]
you're not like uh no no no let me
clarify you wouldn't only have bone
broth no no it would be like an
appetizer yeah yeah it would be like a
beginning and an end to a meal
I feel like 35 I had a little bit of a
software upgrade is that what you are
now yes like I feel like I feel like
35 this minute is happening no but like
there's something about the firmness of
that age to me where it's like you're
not in your early 30s anymore you are a
35 year old woman that just and I'm does
that sound right to you guys is like
being ahead of me or this is just
nonsense of me trying to pretend I'm old
well like okay so I was in therapy
earlier um Dr Drew um recommended this
amazing EMDR lady and so I've been going
to her for it and she was existing you
know she gives a lot of like tidbits
about the brain and whatnot but she was
like your brain really isn't fully
formed until you're 24. like man or
woman and so I'm like wait my brain has
only been fully formed for this amount
of time so it would only make sense to
have like additional like upgrades you
know as we go like a 24 that's an
upgrade right your brain's belief or to
rent that car baby yeah in order to just
get ready to run and so yeah I think
maybe every decade I suppose
um I think I had a really really big one
a forced upgrade last year
or you know when difficulty and then
things like great oh transitions it's
like a force upgrade number one yeah and
you think you think yeah you're you're
forced to really kind of reckon with
like the pieces of you you maybe haven't
like checked in on in a while and you
think you're this you know in the
relationship you've been in it for so
long so you're like oh like this is who
I am this is who I am and then you're
out of it and you're like oh I don't
know parts of myself and you're sad I
know even the really bad ones when
you're like so upset and you're like so
like I can't believe this person left me
it's like you always like six months or
however long it takes later you like
look back and you're like oh this was
the best thing that ever happened no
it's so true like the worse the breakup
the better you are at the end because
you like suffered through you dug down
deep and like had to go through the
depths of hell I mean I have not asked
you this in a while like how are you
what's your current state like how are
you doing are you enjoying being single
do not like it
um
I I I'm trying to be alone I really
really am I'm trying not to be anyone's
girl and
um I was seeing people here and there
really like two people that's it I've
had sex with two boys still trying to
make that tattoo make sense not gonna
happen girl it's never going away either
it's it's pretty serious and no shade to
either of them they're amazing people
but what I learned was no like I am so
far from being ready to be in a
relationship again so if I enter into
something with someone and that person
likes me for real like we're in trouble
because I have no rope I'm out of rope I
still am out of rope I feel so depleted
I can I can't even picture myself being
like a good partner to anybody right now
I cannot picture myself like doing all
the things I did for Bobby to for
someone else but you don't have to do
yeah for Bobby yeah that you did for
Bobby for someone else but that's my
idea of like devotion right where it's
like I have to really be so I I'm really
struggling I'm struggling I know but I'm
struggling Annie I really am like I
don't know how to be alone and I'm now
realizing like I I don't know how to be
alone but I know I need to be alone but
also like to just reach for that phone
and to have someone say I really love
you I'm in love with you and it's it's
so conflict licking because I like the
attention but I'm just not ready
I actually does that make sense or am I
just like well what I I'm lost is what
I'm saying I'm lost I don't know what to
do no no you're in the perfect Point
actually probably to meet someone
because you wouldn't fall into that
pattern of like giving too much like
Annie said like you don't have to give
that much and maybe this is a good time
like if you meet someone and you don't
have a lot to give and it's the right
person then like think of how slow it
would go and how little you wish it was
that way but when someone likes you and
they are ready and they want you
she's getting really serious about that
too
in a row I was just like wondering
that's you're just 35 you'll learn when
you get to 37 38 but even if it is the
right person like I I'm telling you the
last person I dated
incredible
you don't get it when someone loves you
Esther
you fell for it too
so it's like you meet someone who's
incredible who wants to do things for
you who believes in you who has all of
these things and you're just like dude
I'm operating at like 40 I don't know
what to tell you and he's like 40 is
enough but I'm like well my 40 means I'm
not ready to be to be called your
girlfriend I'm not ready to commit to
that like it's a bummer because you
could potentially have just like missed
out on a great opportunity with like a
partner there's no missing out timing's
always Divine it's always the right
thing you think oh yeah like
everything's always happening exactly
how it's supposed to well that's how
that's what I fear I'm like I let go of
two amazing people who really really
such a thrupple [__] this girl cannot
get away from this not at the same time
well she's like look I'm 40. he's 35 and
he wait no wait is that right 60.
yeah so I feel like [__] did I just like
miss my opportunity to incredible two
different people and oh
because I'm just not ready but then this
is like anxiety because then you're
thinking about a thing that already
happened you're right worrying about
that and that's not like being in the
moment and like filling yourself with
what you need to feel to be ready to
actually have a partner right and if
they're and when I'm if it's swing back
around maybe all of your ex-boyfriends
are still in your phone they're all
waiting to tell you that yeah they're
swinging around back around for the
wrong reasons I just had an ex send me a
picture of my 25 year old feet in like
little flip-flops and like without with
no contacts and he was like God you'd be
basically saying like I should like my
feet would make me a lot of money and he
sent me just I'm like who you took that
win just my feeling now they're bleeding
there's Nails I know ruined the money
makers I know what is it like to walk
away from someone who likes you honestly
Esther that's a really good question not
be Pride because genuinely come down
they run into their Panic Room
laughs
it's
so it like it feeds you a certain thing
that you need right obviously like an
ego boost it gives you like the Comfort
when someone's really doting and loves
you and yeah
um it feels amazing but it doesn't feel
amazing when the person is like
I want you to be my girl and I'm like I
cannot be your girl that doesn't feel a
little good it doesn't I cry I've cried
a lot over it I've cried a lot over it
and only because they're good people and
I feel [__] up because even in this
relationship so long so like all these
guys are waiting they struck like
immediately like wait like a second
they're like we're here they're like
you're not ready you're like oh my God
this happened like a second ago leave me
alone yeah but it's fine it's like you
don't want them to wait for you but you
want them to be available-ish to wait
you know yeah and it's not hot if they
were to see them move on would be really
painful for really well you would heal
that pain and that's the pain you need
to feel yeah and I think that's what I
need to
um I think my desire to
be alone overrides my fear of like
losing them I think so that's that's it
for now that's the update I want to make
an amendment to my
my idea of the the writing that people
want to say to you because I think you
just really have to because it has to be
coming from yourself you have to write
yourself the script and read it that's
my wholesale I like that yeah because
you can't control anyone else
and you can't be rely on other people to
tell you what you need to hear
it is true but sometimes you need
comfort I think it's okay to see Comfort
but yes that's why when I film myself
giving myself pep talk
it's so helpful timeout is that which
one the camera guy what is it yeah
you guys thank you so much for joining
us for the electronic Daisy EDC just say
EDC ADC Stagecoach 2.0 we'll see you
guys next week the Jolly do Molly baby
is that the motto I don't know that's so
Good by Annie Letterman do not reflect
those of this podcast she hasn't done it
yet okay we'll get back to you and she's
done it and she'll be like how do we get
a sponsor Please Subscribe and eat a
banana good night bye guys or deep
throat up
thank you
foreign
[Music]